away newton is a fixture here in our  city he is mr las vegas after all he's  been performing in the city for 65 years  he loves it  earlier in the show you heard about one  of his favorite moments when he was  performing it really wasn't too long ago  but it turns out there's something he  really does not like when it comes to  our city  well the one thing that irritates me  beyond words  is when i hear people refer  to this town of sin city  don't do it he says it's because it's no  different than any other big city as far  as sins go and he says we have the  nicest people anywhere wayne newton in  the spotlight all week here on good day  if you missed any of our earlier  segments this week go to 8newsnow.com